[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce dernier
numéro du 7 8 sociétés
les invités sont présents mais à
distance par visio en raison de la crise
sanitaire
l accompagnement de la jeunesse durant
la période estivale constitue un vrai
défi après de nombreuses semaines son
école le gouvernement a souhaité mettre
en place l'opération vacances à
prenantes pour évoquer ce sujet avec
nous charline avenel rectrice de
l'académie de versailles bonjour vous
plonge dans l'âme corinne gros tas air
présidente de la fcpe 78 de la
fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves
bonjour ou oraux et enfin michael le
joug cros professeur de mathématiques au
collège albert thierry de limay bonjour
bonjour elle les vacances apprenantes
vise principalement les jeunes en
situation d'isolement ou empêchés dans
la continuité de leur apprentissage est
particulièrement touché par la fracture
sociale exacerbée par le confinement
ce dispositif est mis en place par le
gouvernement
il y a plus d'intérêt pour les vacances
apprenantes après ce confinement
charline avenel et bien fait ses
vacances à prononcer fait une réponse
absolument indispensable suite la
période que nous avons connue parce que
des élèves ont été éloignés pendant
plusieurs mois que leurs camarades de
leurs écoles certains d'entre eux ne
partent pas en vacances non n'ont pas
l'opportunité et donc permettre ces
vacances apprenants et bien c'est
l'occasion de recréer du lien du périph
d'apprendre de conforter ses
apprentissages et en même temps de faire
des choses extrêmement ludique et
agréable peut le croire quels sont
justement les dispositifs mis en place
alors l'offre est très riche et très
qualitative l eau sur les élèves de
l'école primaire sur les collégiens sur
les lycéens sur les lycéens de la voie
professionnelle qui ont une offre qu'il
aurait proposé qu'il est d'ailleurs
particulièrement
fitch la semaine dernière j'ai du roi il
travaille du potager à l'assiette on
fait la même chose avec le spectacle
baroque
voilà on a une offre très très riches et
puis je vous montrais aujourd'hui un
reportage avec l'académie vous diomède
de football donc bernard diomède
champion du monde en 1998 nous a proposé
ses services pour les collégiens qui ont
envie de travailler et aussi envie de
faire du football à haute dose
mickaël joue trop comment ça se passe
concrètement ses vacances à prenante
dans votre établissement à limay donc il
ya une à l'appel à candidatures pour les
élèves intéressés par par cette semaine
et eu beaucoup beaucoup de demain plus
en tout cas que qu'il était possible
d'accueillir puisque il y avait cinq
professeurs qui s'était proposé pour
encadrer le la semaine on a eu 60
demande donc ils en ont retenu la
direction a retenu trente deux élèves
s'étaient fait le choix de prendre des
6e et les élèves de deux classes du pe 2
à dire des aides non allophones qui sont
une classe qui s'est ouvert cette année
dans l'établissement et donc la semaine
a eu pour thème voyage au travers des
cultures puisque balme attendons qu'ils
ont plutôt travailler sur moi il y avait
du français de l'anglais donc plutôt des
exercices de manière ludique sur voilà
sur des courts on va dire qu'elle s'est
quand même être actif et puis l'après
midi des activités plus ludiques comme
une chasse au trésor une visite du
territoire nous on est sur le sur le
mantois
et donc c'est une zone qui a une grande
histoire du moyen-âge donc le professeur
d'histoire a fait une visite de fêtes de
là où vivent nos élèves et
voilà avec notamment une chasse au
trésor il y avait un pique nique aussi
pour un peu fédérer le groupe est donc
cette visite est une sortie cinéma mais
main en fin de semaine et chaque été
trois millions d'enfants près d'un élève
sur quatre se voient privés de vacances
estivales cette année avec cette crise
sanitaire les jeunes ont été confinés
isolé est ce que ces vacances
apprenantes c'est vraiment ce qui leur
faut corinne creux derrière alors de
toute façon toute proposition qui peut
être fait pour des élèves qui sont en
difficulté ou en tout cas pour réduire
d'une manière générale les inégalités
entre les élèves est une bonne chose
aujourd'hui il y a une possibilité via
c'est la france après mende d'avoir sept
cent mille jeunes en tout qui pourrait
en bénéficier
donc oui c'est une bonne chose
maintenant peut-être que on pourrait
réfléchir pour partir de ces vacances
apprenantes et réussir dans l'école à
faire en sorte que ces inégalités se
creusent à prendre en compte des enfants
qui sont dans des situations difficiles
j'ai envie de vous dire si ça peut être
la première marche sur un court travail
importante ce serait bien charles vanel
une réaction mais ce serait le cas parce
que vraiment il faut voir ses vacances à
prenantes non pas comme quelque chose
qui va se passer uniquement de manière
exceptionnelle la cette année parce
qu'on est dans les cirques en france
connaît mais bien plutôt inscrire ce qui
se passe cet été qui va toucher 25
milles
jeune par l'académie de versailles c'est
à dire que c'est deux fois plus que
d'habitude
eh bien il faut prendre cela comme
quelque chose qui s'inscrit dans un
continuum on a été chercher les élèves
qui étaient les plus fragiles qu'on
avait du mal à toucher pendant leur
confinement
on s'est attaché à essayer de faire en
sorte qu'il reprenne plus rapidement
qu'ils aient des places à l'école
lorsque les écoles ont réouvert cet été
on leur fait un programme spécifique à
la rentrée dont les accompagnera plus
particulièrement également et je pense
que je qui est en train de se passer les
vacances a prononcé péter ouvrira la
voie à bien les choses à partir des
vacances de la toussaint parrainant donc
je vous envoie madame parce que vous
avez raison c'est une première marche
mais la route est longue et en tout cas
celle ci est inspirante et je crois
qu'on va vraiment poursuivre dans cette
logique d'accompagnement personnalisé et
aussi de plaisir retrouvé avec l'école
dans les semaines et les mois à venir
mickaël joue gros ses vacances à
prononcer l'occasion de rattraper ce
retard accumulé pendant le confinement
pour les élèves
je suis pas certain qu semaine de
vacances apprenantes va rattraper trois
mois trois mois fin du mois de mars ou
3d de deux cours à distance qui n'ont
pas été complètement perdue il ya les
travail fait à distance mais au moins de
raccrocher les élèves leur dire va à
l'école est encore là l'école vous
soutiens vous aide et de ne pas les
laisser partir en vacances en sans son
soutien sans un minimum de voix de de
laisser les cds colle encore existantes
pour eux et quand on regarde pas en
septembre comme si tout s'était arrêté
tout le mois de février
fin février en tant que présidente de la
fcpe 78 avez vous eu des remontées de
parents sur les lacunes de leurs enfants
pendant le confinement en mathématiques
en français alors oui on s'est retrouvé
dans une situation où le moko éducation
qui est aussi important après tout
j'allais dire son intensité oui on a des
parents qu'ils étaient dans l'incapacité
de pouvoir aider des enfants parce
qu'ils n'en avaient pas les compétences
des parents qui comprenait à quel point
leurs enfants pouvaient à craon
difficultés des familles qui n'avaient
pas de matériel on s'est retrouvé dans
des situations très compliquées et c'est
là où effectivement il ya eu il ya eu
une augmentation des inégalités
le confinement malgré le travail des
enseignants qu'il est reconnu par tous a
été extrêmement compliqué pour les
élèves parce qu'on n'est pas habitué à
travailler à distance qu'on n'est pas
habitué au delà du manque de matériel
c'est un travail de se retrouver devant
trente élèves et ils nous parents on ne
sait pas faire ce travail là
donc oui ça a été on a eu beaucoup de
remontées qui ont été aussi très
positive en quelquefois là on parle
uniquement des difficultés mais on a eu
aussi des remontées très possible mais
qu'elle vous croient en tant que
professeur faire ses cours à distance
quel était votre ressenti c'est pas
simple ça il ya une phase d'adaptation
au début assez assez assez prenante
parce qu'il a fallu trouver le vin un
bon système
ce qu'on a chaque enseignant a forcément
fait sa proposition et qui lui a semblé
la plus adaptée donc à lui à avoir un
temps il fallait trouver comment
proposer à distance nos co donc moi
prendre pour ma part j'ai mêlé à la fois
une demande d'autonomie parce que vous
pouvez pas être tout le temps en visio
et puis avec pardon de la classe du cned
des cours des moments de rencontres en
virtuel et classe virtuelle on a
beaucoup parlé avec avec les classes
avec nos élèves mais ça n'a pas été
simple parce que si c'est vous n'avez
pas tous vos élèves et que
s'il n'ya pas de réponse en face voilà
vous pouvez pas toc à chaque porte y
avait rendez-vous étaient plus
difficiles à trouver dans la continuité
suivi charline avenel quels sont les
établissements les plus motivés par ces
vacances apprenantes les lycées les
collèges
non moi je trouve tout à fait
exceptionnelle comme d'ailleurs ce fut
le cas par un confinement
l'investissement et l'engagement
l'engagement des listes et de la voie
professionnelle
je leur tire mon chapeau est évidemment
de tous les instituteurs premier degré
les et les collèges nécessite notre
soutien et la valorisation de ce qu'ils
ont fait mais vraiment dans la voix coup
on a des publics qui sont plus fragiles
a été donc plus difficile d'aller les
chercher de les rendre présents dans les
classes virtuelles de leur proposer des
modules de formation professionnelle on
a un enseignant qui a transformé son
salon en atelier d'ébénisterie par
exemple mais qui scénique sur une chaîne
youtube pour pouvoir continuer à faire
les enseignements professionnels
et puis là ce qui se passe pendant les
vacances c'est vraiment très très
intéressante avait rien de la voie
professionnelle
on essaye de les mettre contacts
d'entreprises on essaie de les mettre au
contact de deux lieux culturels de sport
de faire le lien avec ce qu'ils ont à
apprendre dans l'eure dans leur métier
voyez par exemple on fait des ateliers
de cuisine dans certains lycées
professionnels et du coup voilà je crois
qu'on on ré enchanter aussi les
apprentissages les métiers et on est à
l'interstice des vacances du plaisir et
puis des apprentissages et donc je
trouve qu'on se réinvente beaucoup sur
la voie crude en ce moment et nos élèves
en ont particulièrement besoin mais
qu'elle joue ce rôle l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure certains élèves n'ont pas pu
participer à ces vacances apprenantes
comment ça se passe pour ces élèves
justement alors ce qu'il faut quand même
dire c'est que et monsieur joue court on
est
on est la preuve c'est qu'on a quand
même une mobilisation tout à fait
substantielle des enseignants et des
chefs d'établissement qui se sont portés
volontaires comme comme la dans
l'établissement vous travaillez monsieur
malheureusement en effet on répond pas à
tout le monde par ce dispositif là mais
pendant les vacances il ya quand même un
ensemble de dispositifs qui ont été
mises en place qui ne repose pas tout
sur l'éducation nationale il se passe
des choses du côté jeunesse et sports
avec les colos prenantes qui se passe
des choses parce que les collectivités
locales la région par exemple a mis à
disposition tous ses partenariats avec
des fédérations sportives avec
l'accroché également absolument donc
malheureusement on peut pas répondre à
toute la demande et je me réjouis
qu'elle soit au civil et que les
enseignants aient répondu aux côtes en
plaisant qui le font sur les panneaux
bête mais je suis rassurée par le fait
qu'il ya d'autres dispositifs et ce qui
nous importe peu liquide et publics état
et ses terrasses et de pouvoir bien se
mettre d'accord et partager l'ensemble
des élèves pour s'assurer que et bien un
maximum de jeunes vont pouvoir profiter
de l'un ou l'autre des dispositifs
qu'ils soient éducation nationale ou
autres d'esprit à poissy le collège les
grands-champs accueille depuis le 6
juillet dernier une centaine d'élèves du
cm2 à la troisième dans le cadre de
l'opération des vacances apprenantes un
dispositif mêlant enseignement et sports
le rendez-vous est piloté par l'académie
fondée par le champion du monde 98 de
bernard diomède regard des alliés le
football et les cours pendant les
vacances scolaires le collège les grands
champs de poissy propos ce dispositif
depuis le 6 juillet dernier près d'une
centaine d'élèves participent à ce
programme pris en charge par l'éducation
nationale et la ville dans le cadre des
vacances apprenantes cette particularité
c'est qu'on accueille des élèves des
trois collèges de poissy desgrandchamps
donc notre là où on est actuellement le
collège le corbusier le collège jaurès
et même quelques cm2 qui vont rentrer en
sixième dans les prochaines sont
également
oui pour faire un groupe la homogène
unis par la passion du foot là c'est la
première chose et qu'ils sont prêts à
travailler tous les matins et vraiment
c'est à renouveler au programme chaque
jour des cours de deux heures le matin
avec au planning des mathématiques et du
français
les élèves se dirigent ensuite vers des
ateliers de football une recette qui
fonctionne
je trouve que c'est bien surtout que on
travaille on fait on fait du travail
après on va faire du sport surtout le
sport que j'aime bien le foot je trouve
que c'est bien parce que mon travail
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup travaillé
pendant que coronavirus et en même temps
après le travail ont partagé le foot
français
moi je préfère le foot mais c'est comme
travailler aussi ce stage de football
éducatif est organisée en partenariat
avec l'académie du champion du monde
1998 bernard diomède un parrain
prestigieux qui a permis de médiatiser
ce dispositif
je pense que le foot a légèrement
orientés l'inscription des élèves
la plupart sont tous des footballeurs
ils sont la plupart licenciés ou en club
il ya très peu de d'élèves qui ne l'ont
jamais de foot au pardon même s'il y en
a sur une très bonne formule après une
demi-heure de football premier verdict
c'est un peu compliqué parce que va ça
faisait longtemps que j'en avais patek
donc c'est un peu compliqué mais sinon
tout va bien bah franchement c'est bon
aussi
on sait chauffer un peu et ça fait du
bien puisque avec le court n'avions pas
toutes les équipes ont repris dans le
cas voir cette grande première à poissy
se terminera ce mercredi 15 juillet pour
clôturer la session bernard diomède
devrait de nouveau être présent ce
mercredi matin pour donner quelques
conseils sportifs et sur l'éducation
charline avenel un programme comme celui
de poids si c'est vraiment
représentatifs des vacances à prenantes
pour l'académie de versailles
max est représentatif dans le dans le
mix d'activités ludiques et sur les
apprentissages en ce temps le dans le
plaisir que l'on les élèves à y être et
je crois dans la conscience qu'ils ont
que ces semaines sont importantes pour
eux et que d'être au contact de l'école
c'est important
donc en ce sens c c'est représentatif
alors il n'y a pas forcément dans tous
les collèges des champions du monde de
la coupe du monde qu'ils viennent voir
les élèves mais franchement une très
belle programmation partout et de
l'activité culturelle du sport et donc
lorsque bernard diomède est venu me voir
il ya trois semaines jour pour jour en
me disant je suis disponible pour pour
mettre à disposition l'ensemble des
formateurs de foule
c'est mon académie pour ses vacances et
bien c'est tout naturellement que on a
en a conclu cet accord et qu'on a
travaillé ensemble très rapidement pour
pouvoir proposer à ces jeunes
ce programme qui en effet est assez
alléchant ses vacances apprenantes mail
on l'a vu le sport mais parfois la
culture comme par exemple des visites au
potager du roi ou encore à la maison
elsa triolet aragon saml donc
apprentissage mais aussi détente c'est
ce qu'il faut corinne gros terre pour
les enfants oui alors les vacances
apprenantes j'ai envie de vous dire que
toutes les vacances sont qu'à prenantes
c'est à dire que les enfants apprennent
ou qu'il soit en les vacances à l'école
chez eux peu importe
l'idée étant aujourd'hui qu'il y ait un
développement finalement des compétences
sont sans vraiment scolarisé l'enfant et
c'est quelque chose quelque chose de
très bien d'une manière générale je
pense que l on l'intérêt est
effectivement de pouvoir à l'aîné la
culture dans l'apprentissage et c'est un
phénomène qui est important comme les
places culture j'ai envie de vous dire
qu'ils auraient pu être effectivement
envisagée pour permettre aux enfants
d'aller dans les musées de pouvoir
sortir même dans la région et même pour
ceux qui ne bougeait pas aujourd'hui
mais oui la culture est quelque chose de
fondamental dans l'équipe dans
l'éducation d'une manière générale
et tant mieux c'est les vacances à
prenantes peuvent aider à la développer
encore plus dans la scolarité de
l'enfant
mickaël joue gros en tant que professeur
de mathématiques une réaction je suis
tout à fait la culture c'est important
c'est d'en haut par habitude notre
enseignement et nous notamment dans
notre établissement
on essaie d'emmener tous nos élèves en
tout cas maximum à la rencontre des
cultures quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit
la culture sportive où la culture
artistique le théâtre voilà dès qu'on a
cette possibilité de leur faire
connaître aussi le monde extérieur
qu'ils changent de ce qu'ils voient à la
télé par exemple puisque c'est quand
même leur la télé ou téléphone hors
média principaux c'est une chose
importante de les ouvrir au monde
extérieur aussi corinne greutert c'est
aussi un soulagement pour les parents
très sollicité pendant le confinement
alors soulagement soulagement de savoir
qu'on peut donner à leurs enfants une
possibilité de pouvoir accéder à la
culture de pouvoir essayer de réduire
entre guillemets les difficultés qu'ils
avaient oui c'est un soulagement
je mettrai juste un bémol en disant que
malheureusement on a quand même des
parents qu'on n'arrive pas à toucher et
c'est souvent des parents dont les
enfants peuvent être en très grande
difficulté il a eu effectivement un
travail des directeurs pour le proposer
aux familles mais bien évidemment ce
n'était pas obligatoire et peut être que
ça s'est fait vite et c'est normal on a
été dans une période de crise donc ça a
dû se faire vite mais peut-être on a
oublié de de communiqué enfin on n'a pas
eu le temps en tout cas de communiquer
assez correctement et du coup on a
laissé des enfants à côté
voilà c'est le regret que je pourrais
avoir mais alors là de la coupe de père
sablon
c'est vraiment un manque de temps
il peut être quelquefois besoin
communiqué longuement avec les familles
pour leur faire comprendre en quoi ça
peut être important
charline avenel une réaction sur ce
manque de temps cette réactivité où il
c'est vrai qu'on a on a fait des choses
pratiques pour répondre présent avant
pâques ans apprenant mais ceci est
monsieur je pense dans votre
établissement ç'a dû être le cas les
enseignants les les principes ou les
produisent pas vraiment tâche est de
cibler prioritairement les élèves qui
avaient le plus besoin de ses vacances à
prenantes et je constate dans les
différents déplacements que j'ai fait la
semaine dernière au potager du roi j'en
ai fait un autre dans une commune des
hauts-de-seine
je remarque les enseignants ont fait ce
travail de ciblage et les élèves ont
plutôt répondu présent ainsi que leurs
familles donc c'est plutôt une bonne
surprise pour moi parce que je ne
pensais pas qu'ils hésitent us israël à
une telle adhésion écouter élèves eux
mêmes qui sont le sourire en arrivant le
lundi matin dans leur école ouverte et
qui ont très clairement conscience que
leur place est là aujourd'hui
avant de clôturer cette émission un
petit tour de table
on l'a vu donc ce dispositif des
vacances apprenantes effet pour pour les
élèves pour les aider pour une rentrée
réussie mais avez vous peur du niveau
des élèves à la rentrée on va commencer
par vaux michaëlle jean cros alors oui
et non forcément il ya eu une longue
période sans travail maintenant les
programmes sont fait que de telle façon
que vous reverra discipline vous revenez
toujours sur une notion qui a des vues
avant pour la prolonger à aller plus
loin dans cette notion en apportant des
nouveautés et c'est donc finalement
quand on en a pas avec mes collègues
avant de partir en vacances
on s'est dit mais eux effectivement il y
aura du retard des de ceux qui n'auront
pas été vus correctement mais comme on
va revenir dessus
voilà on s'est dit que ça allait les
choses pouvaient reprendre les piles
élèves s'adapte aussi l'habitude
d'apprendre et dé temps dans un mode
d'apprentissage et je pense que il
je pense qu'elle peut bien se passer il
y aura besoin de soutien
ces choses qui vont être mises en place
jusque jusqu'aux vacances de la
toussaint sur les premières semaines et
donc pour les plus décrocheurs on va
aussi du coup récupérer la fagne tout le
monde soit à peu près au même niveau et
qu'on soit dans un dans un dans un élan
d'apprentissage collectif qui ce
qu'espère dans les meilleures conditions
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure une
semaine de vacances à prenantes
ce n'est pas suffisant mais avec du
soutien ça ira pour les élèves
espérons le en tout cas tout le monde
fera tout pour que ce soit pour que les
élèves réussissent leur année même si
elle sera forcément étrange par rapport
à d'habitude bien sûr corps et une
grotte à air en tant que présidente de
la fcpe 78 alors je les envie de vous
dire je vais répondre de deux manières
au niveau des compétences des élèves je
pense qu'on a eu la chance ce n'est pas
une chance mais c'en est une est
aujourd'hui de d'avoir tout lé d'élèves
de france et de navarre qui aurait été
confinés et donc on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec des élèves qui rentrent
en septembre qui auront tous
effectivement trois mois de confinement
avec une continuité pédagogique qui
n'est pas la manière dont qu'ils
apprennent d'habitude donc effectivement
au niveau compétences pur il y aura très
certainement des choses qui ne seront
pas acquise
mais ce sera valable dans toutes les
matières et pour tous les élèves
rentrent 3 entre trois et six années
s'ils vont glisser au delà de 16 ans
maintenant peut-être que ce qui va être
plus difficile c'est pas uniquement ce
champ de compétence c'est que un
confinement pour les élèves c'est aussi
psychologiquement quelque chose qui est
compliqué à vivre
on a privé les enfants entre limay de
leur vie sociale pendant deux mois et
demi nous adultes on appris de facilité
à pouvoir le faire
eux ne peuvent pas et n'ont pas pu le
faire donc je pense que ça va être aussi
compliqué pour pour du coup les
enseignants et les parents de pouvoir
essayer de faire en sorte que leurs
enfants aujourd'hui reprennent
une vie ou essayent de reprendre une vie
comme avant si on peut reprendre une vie
comme avant ça ça va être quand même
quelque chose est un challenge pour les
enseignants notamment
charline avenel il va se passer beaucoup
de choses à la rentrée d'abord on ne
rompt donnera la possibilité aux
enseignants de mener des tests de
positionnement
et puis en 6e par exemple il ya des
évaluations qui vont être refaits ces
moments sont particulièrement important
parce qu'il nous permet ils vont nous
permettre de vous permettre aux
enseignants de bien mesurer l'état des
apprentissages des élèves
en conséquence de quoi il leur sera
ensuite facile d'apporter des réponses
aux besoins de renforcement rondes et
des élèves en fonction de leur niveau et
de là où ils en seront et de ce point de
vue il ya quand même plusieurs
dispositifs qui vont être mises en place
l'une des grandes tendances qu'on
observe à par confinement c'est le
besoin de tutorat le besoin
d'accompagnement personnalisé et bien
les établissements auront les moyens de
le faire à la rentrée notamment parce
que vient un peu technique mais il y
avait un ensemble d'oeuvres qui n'avait
pas été consommés pendant l'année nous
avons fait remonter au niveau de
l'académie et que nous avons redistribué
il l'est les équipes dont les élèves ont
le plus besoin de ses efforts
d'accompagnement de tutorat il ya des
opérations par exemple comme devoirs
faits qui doivent reprendre tout de
suite dès la rentrée au collège le plus
rapidement possible et qui apporte un
confort aux élèves et des capacités d'un
problème en supplémentaire donc voilà à
la rentrée c'est important de savoir
vraiment et un que scientifiquement où
en sont les élèves et c'est important à
partir de cela 2 m de mettre en oeuvre
et des solutions de rattrapage
d'accompagnement pourquoi les
établissements auront quelques marges de
manoeuvre ultime question le port du
masque sera-t-il obligatoire pour les
professeurs à la rentrée et bien port du
masque sera probablement obligatoire à
l'intérieur des lieux fermés comme ce
sera le cas d'ailleurs il avait entendu
hier sur un certain nombre d'activités
voilà sur la rentrée et plus largement
les conditions sanitaires de cette
rentrée elle devrait se faire à priori
dans les conditions dans lesquelles se
sont fait les dernières semaines de juin
évidemment nous nous réservons la côte
imiter nous ajuster en fonction des
préconisations et des plantes qui se
répètent par les autorités sanitaires
mais est ce à quoi je crois maintenant
ensemble de l'éducation nationale est
bien préparée merci merci à tous d'avoir
participé à cette dernière émission de
la saison et dernière émission pour moi
je tenais à remercier certains de mes
collègues mais aussi les techniciens la
régie les monteurs toutes ces personnes
que vous ne voyez pas mais qui font
partie de cette émission je retiendrai
les bons moments les belles rencontres
grâce à atv 78 merci à vous également de
votre fidélité
bonne continuation sur tv 78 avec
d'autres présentateurs à la rentrée
belle soirée
[Musique]